is kind of hostile when you're like I
don't I there are no barriers to what I
want congratulations that means you have
a privilege where you're not facing any
friction and that's showing and I feel
like I think there's an American I think
as an American you're very privileged
I'm not ignoring that yeah like a basic
level of what I mean the feminist
movement is when it comes to just being
born a woman right physically pound for
pound we are born as women and we have
less lean muscle mass than men so there
are issues of violence and assault and
stuff like that and so therefore there
are policies are things to help women
physically like for example I believe
being able to carry a firearm and being
able to use that safely to defend
yourself against men who are born
naturally with more muscle mass than a
woman